hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's 2 let's continue our second
night shall we now in the first episode
I was in a total and utter panic because
I had no idea what was going on but
ivory collected my thoughts and I have
an idea as to what is necessary to win
this game but first hello-o I told you
your first night wouldn't be a problem
you're a natural by now I'm sure you've
noticed the older model sitting in the
back room those are from the previous
location which is you number parts now
and idea first was the repair them they
even started retrofitting them with some
of the newer technology for just so ugly
you know so the company decided to just
go in a whole new direction and make
them super kid friendly wait those older
ones shouldn't be able to walk around
but if they do the whole Freddy head
trick should work on them too so
whatever yeah I love those characters
the diversity party the pirate II await
fun oh yeah coffee hey listen that one
was always a bit twitchy
I'm not sure if the Freddy head trick
will work on r2 if for some reason he
activates through the night and see
we're standing in the mind of them all
just flash your light atom from time to
time the older models are disoriented
with bright lights system restart or
something because I think of it I try to
have my enjoy to wear something
undesirable nightly you might holding
the plate for me singing English my
period with the newer models - one more
thing don't forget the music bar I'll be
honest I never liked that other thing
anyway my problem oh okay oh it's gone
good the new foxy seem to have moved oh
oh here you here you who's mommy wait
who's moving who love it who the hell is
moving okay so anyway III did not know
that about the light but I had a theory
about the end of the hallway yeah yeah
foxes Grogg oh hi
why are you there I thought this is
gonna be the old foxy those gonna be
coming after me not the new one that's a
weird about the base in two parts
Oh God where's Balloon Boy oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god
bye-bye where's Balloon Boy this is too
early to make what ok this far too early
to be making me panic like this where is
Balloon Boy
I knew that balloon guy was not to be
trusted where the all right no good god
no oh hai hai hai hai hai flash five
five five five oh god oh god oh god
flash hunger oh god I can't do it I fell
fast okay I don't know what's going on
here
there's Bad News Bears oh god this is
too much why are you doing this it's not
okay I have a feeling that the old foxy
didn't like that new foxy too much but
why is the new Fox yep two heads Oh what
am I supposed to do about hai hai hai
hai
what the hell no no no no no no no no no
no no Dada da Dada Dada Dada Dada oh my
god this is a little too much for the
second night don't you think
oh god how am I supposed to keep track
of everything I can't even think enough
to talk who's cool move moving you're in
there you're in there why is Balloon Boy
a part of this he was not invited to
this pocket
oh hi Bonnie
okay oh god oh god oh don't tell me I
get night blindness from that thing
iiiii whoa what huh well what not okay
not okay not okay not okay okay so
anyway was gonna save this hallway down
the middle it's actually a long hallway
if you look at the map it's just
straight down all the party rooms and
then they're gonna be shown on the sides
of them No
why is this a thing got to him it's not
okay I was not ready for this night to
be like this okay okay okay okay okay
all right
bang thang thang thang thang thang thang
why am i saving back I don't even know
oh god okay oh hi foxy okay he's all the
way at the end of the hallway there's
like distance in between what's going on
in between Oh God - my flashlights not
work sometimes Oh God no no no no no no
no no no let me let me slash that's not
okay oh man what is Balloon Boy
oh oh that's not okay oh my god I can't
even think about what I'm doing right
now there's so much to keep track of at
all times
oh hi foxy again again with you where's
your friend where's your bro where's the
other foxy everyone's gone Oh God
okay we're okay I think I'm starting to
get the rhythm of the night til the
morning light gonna know so there are
times when I can't flash down the
hallway hi Freddie what are you doing
here
hi ho hi
what the hell okay Freddie oh my god
oh my god Freddie don't
oh hi Freddie
I'm in here so screw you
fine I am and good to deal with this
bowl we think I'm not doing this - y'all
ready for this - I don't want to wake
the baby
yes okay okay all right okay all right
good god there are so many things to
worry about what oh I'm back here again
if you guys couldn't tell Oh
let me tell you
Oh also why is the guy on the phone
still alive it's not right it's got to
be some way that like he died but he's
not actually dead he's part of it all
he's part of it all he's got to be yeah
100 company would have any problems
yeah party over a pair of the hallway oh
my god I was just curious like I said
even though it's my favorite they tried
to remake monsuno they both of Marshalls
too scary
so they redesigned to be more
kid-friendly put his toe it keep it off
entertain but these Asians can't keep
their hands to themselves the fat
literally has a funky back together
every ship eventually they just not try
and lent them or sometimes take apart
put back together attraction massive
heart makes employees refer someone to
the mango needy oh hey before I go I
wanted to ease your mind about any
rumors you might have heard lately you
know how these local stories coming over
seldom eat and sing I can burn poetry
whatever is going on out there however
Connecticut maybe has message to do a
better tablet that's all rumor and
speculation people trying to make above
email our guard during the day has
reported something they leave on watch a
little bit of your clothes okay well
anyway hang in there how is this a place
for kids
how is this friendly place it's not in
Foxy's being a really big douche right
now I don't want to appreciate it
oh hi I own chica oh my goodness gravy
where's old bunny where's old bunny
where's my body oh my god no whenever
that music pops up it means bad and it's
really bad all of this means really bad
and I don't like it
oh hi foxy how you doing okay
I don't know I'm what who's it who's in
the men's is it Balloon Boy that douche
below ha ha ah busybox means bug these
bugs good a beauty box
oh oh god oh god oh god oh god I don't
know I go and come close dad's
who's there oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god memories memories
memories koga oh it's the older oh god
it's the old one oh god where's where's
he where's you know what to do
Oh God
I'm in a blind panic from the Mona I
start to the moment I die all right
let's do this this is the most stressful
I've ever had I'm literally shaking I
can't take it this is the most stressful
game I've ever played in my goddamn life
I don't know what to do they throw new
stuff at me which is really cool because
it's the old stuff and then Barney comes
back it's got the face and she gets come
back it he's like he knows like three
sets of teeth I think I saw like maybe
three or four sets of teeth I don't even
don't care about the baby anymore
goddamn I don't care about waking up the
baby let all the little baby bloody
sleep on a sleepy sleep whatever that
music comes up music
my mask until it's time to go hi foxy
means someone's about to enter the
hallway so I need to like let him do his
thing I don't know what I forgot what to
do for the animatronics so I just need
to flash him in the light because that
bonnie was in the room putting on the
mask seemed like a horrible error
probably okay got this damn music box
forcing me to not be quick about this
because one thing I am about this game
is very quick I got that when I did 420
mode back in the day way long ago when I
was like a year younger or so it feels
okay where are you guys where are you
guys the balloon boys still there what
all right Foxy's gonna pay me a visit
box is gonna wave hi it's all gonna be
good there's fun
it's got flashing glass them a whole
bunch show them my donger you'll go away
that's at least that's what the internet
told me that's all he's after he's just
after for the pirate booty if you know
what I mean no no no no no no no hi hey
I'm gonna flash you so hard right now
Bonnie god you're disgusting
I mean you look good or whatever I don't
know whatever you want to hear where to
go pretty good pretty good pretty did it
go away good good
hey he does have like 15 sets of teeth
right now it's not okay lease it's
obvious it's not the teeth of the fallen
was that kisses metal endoskeleton
showing up a bit okay okay
who's in the back Susan the bench who's
in the [ __ ] bodies are the vents okay
so that means when he's in the room
which is gonna be any minute now I don't
put on my mask I don't think it's gonna
fool him
oh hi boxy okay I knew it was gonna be
foxy okay I'm starting to get the rhythm
of the night and I want to be able to
beat this damn game hi oh god am i dead
I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead what the
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that is not okay so I just got a hold
still is I gonna do
what is this Oh what is what was that is
it the moon marionette I think people
come I'm gonna call the army because
that's what that thing is you don't want
to wake the baby Dogon is your box run
out and wake the baby okay I'm gonna
follow you what the hell is going on oh
I don't have a goddamn clue what just
happened okay I don't know why was that
even how do you get away from Barney he
went away and then I was dead
Oh okay I'm gonna I got through one more
night so that was my only goal for this
episode but 93 is gonna be a bit of a
[ __ ]
Tony the way I'm gonna finish up in
another episode Melvin's trying guys
about this and actually get it down cuz
I just got to figure out how to do it I
get the other ones down it's gotta
figure out with the olden don't ask why
my fingers green thank you all so much
for watching click the nd take some more
videos that I've done especially more
five nights at Freddy's there's two
animations to see they're both awesome
thanks again everyone and as always I
will see you in the next video
Rasika zone fun chicken
I didn't
I am The King